أريد أن أتوقف لحظة
لأريكم مقطع فيديو التقطه منتجنا في CNN في
القدس ، إنه يحظى
باهتمام كبير على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، حيث يظهر امرأة
تتحدث إلى ضابط شرطة إسرائيلي
تم
اعتقالها للتو في احتجاج ضد الإخلاء.
اه استمع
وراقب هذا
ماذا فعلت فقط للدفاع عن فتاة
تعرضت للضرب
ولهذا السبب تم اعتقالي الآن تعتقد أنك
دفاع عن الناس الذين سيتم
طردهم من منازلهم
كيف تشعر أنك لا أعرف ذلك  أنت
إنسان
وربما لديك عائلة لديك أطفال ،
هل تريد
أن يكبر أطفالك وينمو كل شيء
للدفاع عن الجانب الخطأ
إذا كان أي شخص يدافع عن الظالمين المظلومين
هذا ما فعلته هذا ما أردت
أن تكونه عندما كنت  عندما كنت صغيرًا عندما كنت
طفلاً
لتكون في الجانب الخطأ ، هذا ما كنت
تريده
عندما كنت طفلاً تحلم بأن يكبر
[موسيقى
] وكان لديك أحلام كبيرة ، هذا ما أردت
أن تكون في مرأى من الظالمين
حسنًا في إسرائيل  تم تعيين المحكمة
لاتخاذ ش  -
قضية الإخلاء في حي الشيخ جراح
لكن الجلسة التي كانت
مقررة اليوم تأجلت